Marouane c'est un jeune garçon qui a 22
ans
ou 24 ans 25 ans
qui ne travaille pas qui habite
dans le dans le département de Loire il
dit avec ses parents c'est un garçon
gentil c'est un garçon serviable et
aux alentours du 20 septembre il part
passer quelques jours chez un de ses
copains ses amis qui s'appelle Jérémy
d'accord lequel Jérémy habite à
Saint-Germain les Arpajon d'accord dans
le dans le 91 OK et à partir de là on
aura plus ou quasiment plus de contact
avec Marwan en tout cas la famille ira
très peu de contacts avec Marwan il
appelle on sait qui bordent à
Saint-Germain-lès-Arpajon son téléphone
le 23 septembre est à
Saint-Germain-lès-Arpajon et on sort
ensuite on le voit physiquement je crois
le le
le même jour le 23 par la vidéo
surveillance de la ville alors c'est
quelle était sa relation avec la
personne qu'il hébergeait c'est quoi
l'histoire alors ils étaient à priori
très amis il se voyait de loin en loin
mais il s'était rapproché ces derniers
temps d'accord parce qu'à l'origine le
Jérémy est originaire aussi de loi et
donc ils se sont ils se sont vus à cette
à cette époque là
alors pendant ce quelques jours il se
passe quoi alors pendant ces quelques
jours on sait pas très bien à ce
moment-là ce qui se passe ce qui est sûr
c'est que les parents de Marouane vont
signaler sa disparition à la gendarmerie
de Senlis le 1er octobre bon il a 22 ans
c'est entre guillemets un grand garçon
donc au départ on s'inquiète pas trop et
puis le temps passe c'est évidemment les
parents les parents s'inquiète signal sa
disparition à la gendarmerie qui prend
l'affaire très au sérieux tout de suite
par la famille on sait ils savent les
gendarmes savent que
l'existent l'existence de Jérémy et donc
ils vont s'intéresser à Jérémy mais en
même temps ils ont pas un cadre
juridique qui qui font quoi penser
quelque chose parce que c'est quoi c'est
quoi cette affaire de de drogue de tu
sais quoi alors Jérémy est un gros
consommateur et accessoirement un dealer
d'une drogue de synthèse c'est les
nouvelles drogues c'est le 3 MMC alors
ça c'est une drogue explosive qui est un
mélange elle produit les effets de elle
cumule les effets de la coque de
l'ecstasie et de la kétanine d'accord la
tente un médicament pour traiter les
anesthésies de des chevaux donc
c'est quelque chose de très dur et
visiblement ce garçon Jérémy
fonctionnait à ça organisait des soirées
chez lui à Saint-Germain-lès-Arpajon où
ils vivaient en colocation avec une
jeune femme
et il faisait des soirées musique un peu
techno technival alors
Marouane est alors victime de violence
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé alors Marouane
de ce que je sais est devenu petit à
petit le souffre-douleur de Jérémy qui
avait un comportement complètement
transformé par les les drogues qu'ils
absorbaient je précise que Jérémy que
oui Jérémy est un garçon de bonne
famille
c'est parents sont divorcés mais c'est
c'est les gens c'est des gens des gens
bien et
Jérémy a sombré complètement dans cette
consommation de de drogue qui transforme
totalement sa personnalité et il a joué
Orange mécanique à lui tout seul on
parle de torture d'actes de Barla
barbarie c'est ça a été ultra violent
alors j'ai pas les j'ai pas les détails
si vous voulez et puis je j'ai la tente
en face de moi
nous rejoignez à 20h52 on parle de cette
affaire et de Marouane qui avait disparu
il avait disparu fin septembre
et là on a appris le dénouement tragique
de cette affaire pourquoi il était parti
Marouane mais elle est partie voir des
copains tout simplement comme un jeune
adulte de 24 ans à l'aube de ses 25 ans
et
il était parti passer quelques jours
chez un ami vous saviez qu'il allait
chez se Jérémy qui consommait ses
parents mais on savait pas qu'il
consommait des drogues dures comme ça
ses parents étaient au courant parce que
Marouane disait tout à sa famille
c'était pas quelqu'un de de fermer chez
lui
vous avez appris quand la disparition de
Marouane en fait on savait qu'il est
pour nous il était chez un copain et
après comme je vous dis il est adulte
donc si notre neveu ou notre enfant nous
appelle pas pendant deux jours on
s'inquiète pas forcément parce que on se
dit mais avec tes copains on va pas
voilà et on a commencé à s'inquiéter
quand
les amis a commencé vraiment à
s'inquiéter quand le 29 septembre il
devait fêter ses 25 ans et déjà la
veille on n'avait pas de nouvelles et
quelques jours avant et là le 29 quand
vraiment
nos anniversaires chez nous c'est
important on est très famille et
c'est un jour important surtout un quart
de siècle donc là pas de nouvelles
messagerie toujours pas de nouvelles
donc la l'inquiétude elle est montée
d'un cran et là les parents
commençaient à appeler les copains avant
quand même d'alarmer la gendarmerie on
essaie de joindre les copains les amis
l'entourage vous avez
vous avez rapidement soupçonné les
individus chez qu'il dormait ou pas du
tout bah oui enfin je sais pas qu'on a
soupçonné mais c'est que c'était les
seules personnes qui l'ont vu c'était le
seul qui l'avait vu à ce moment là et
[Musique]
et Marouane c'était pas quelqu'un qui
avait pour habitude de disparaître
c'était la première fois c'était pas un
fugueur c'était pas j'avais pas de
problème personnels ou professionnel
vous avez essayé d'appeler les gens chez
qui il était ben mon beau-frère a essayé
de joindre le père de Marouane oui
d'accord
non bah non rien il lui a dit qu'il
était parti le lundi 26 en direction de
Barbès pour réparer un téléphone cassé
mais
ça nous paraissait bizarre qu'on aille
réparé un téléphone alors que Marouane
il était parti que pour quelques jours
il avait pas d'affaires sur lui il avait
pas sa carte bleue il avait pas tout ça
donc il connaît pas Barbès c'est pas des
quartiers qui fréquentent
alors le corps de Marouane a ensuite été
retrouvé déplacé à nombreuses reprises
c'est ça alors et ça c'est absolument
incroyable officiellement il est mort le
24 septembre tous les témoignages
il a été étranglé alors est-ce qu'il a
été pendu est-ce qu'il a été étouffé en
tout cas il a Adrien les causes de la
mort c'est c'est ça c'est le
stangulation
et après avoir donné la mort à Marouane
Jérémy va faire absolument n'importe
quoi avec le corps de ce de ce garçon
tout d'abord il va le mettre dans une
chambre de l'appartement ensuite il va
le dissimuler déjà dans un ascenseur
faut préciser qu'il travaille dans une
société d'ascenseur donc il a le les
clés pour
Jérémy travaille dans une société
d'ascenseur et donc il a les clés pour
pour ouvrir ça et donc il a déposé le
corps un premier temps dans un ascenseur
ensuite pour des raisons olfactives il
va l'enlever de là le mettre dans la
voiture de sa colocataire ensuite il
trouve une cave du côté des Ulis et là
pour les mêmes raisons il va falloir
qu'il retire le corps est dans une
valise scotchée et il va rester
finalement dans le coffre de la voiture
pendant plusieurs jours
Jérémie par travailler avec le corps
dans le coffre de sa voiture enfin c'est
hallucinant ce qui est fou dans cette
histoire c'est que l'ami en question
Jérémy serait même proposé de faire les
recherches avec la famille c'est ça un
maître
ce serait proposé de faire les
recherches avec vous alors moi Cyril
déjà je voudrais vous préciser que ce
que je viens d'entendre de Michel nous
nous sommes pas au courant de tous ces
détails là d'accord donc mon
intervention et notre intervention ce
soir elle n'est pas de venir vous donner
et peut-être et bien répondre à une soif
de curiosité
morbide de la part des téléspectateurs
elle est de plusieurs ordres alors déjà
déjà de vous dire et la famille tient à
cela de remercier et à un moment à
l'heure où l'on parle de réforme de la
police nationale de dire et de remercier
aux enquêteurs dans le cadre de cette
procédure-là avec leur abnégation avec
leur sagacité d'être arrivé jusqu'à la
découverte du corps de Marouane et
ensuite l'identification puis
l'interpellation des auteurs présumés ça
c'est la première des choses et la
deuxième motivation de la présence de
Zakia ce soir
c'est de dire que ça n'est que le début
et que et bien si la découverte du qui a
fait ça était indispensable est un
préalable indispensable ça n'est
évidemment pas suffisant et donc la
famille attend beaucoup de l'institution
judiciaire elle attend qu'elle réponde à
un certain nombre de questions et
notamment le pourquoi par exemple parce
que les investigations qui vont être
amenés et les questions que se posent la
famille et notamment et bien une
question principale pour la mère parce
qu'il va falloir que le juge
d'instruction dans le cadre de ces
investigations viennent dire à la mer et
viennent lui expliquer pourquoi pourquoi
on lui a enlevé son petit ange comme
elle a dit et certains membres d'autres
questions et une échelle a commencé à y
répondre il est journaliste et il peut
il peut en toute en toute facilité
violée le secret de l'instruction pour
ma part je ne peux pas vous donner de
détails et ça n'est pas l'objet de mon
Inter bien sûr mettre et Zakia et Michel
il y a une question qu'on se pose à
chaque fois quand il arrive des armes
comme ça est-ce qu'il aurait pu être
évité est-ce qu'il était connu des
services de police Jérémy
Jérémy à ma connaissance n'était pas
connu des services de police en revanche
pour répondre à votre question est-ce
que ce drame aurait pu être évité j'ai
envie de vous répondre oui parce qu'il y
a un moment dans la soirée ou
Marouane est encore vivant mais déjà
victime de nombreux coups il y a deux
témoins des des gens de la
Seine-Saint-Denis qui tentent de
s'interposer et face à la furie de
Jérémy ont préféré battre en retraite ah
c'est ça ils ont quitté la soirée
et ils ont pas prévenu la police et
s'ils avaient prévenu la police
peut-être que
Marouane serait encore vivant claqua
vous connaissiez cet élément oui oui je
le savais depuis oui je
de cet élément et donc ils ont pas même
pas prévenu la police ils sont rentrés
tranquillement chez eux sachant qu'il y
avait un drame qui jouait c'est ce que
j'ai comme information bon maintenant on
est dans un milieu très particulier de
gens qui se mettent des des mines grâce
à ce produit donc je joue dont je vous
parlais tout à l'heure
ce qui n'est en aucun cas une
circonstance atténuante on est bien
d'accord mais c'est pour vous planter le
contexte
aujourd'hui on a entendu Nabil elou
Chikli le l'avocat de la famille juste
qu'est-ce que vous attendez de la
justice aujourd'hui
comme je vous disais
Cyril
l'objectif d'une procédure judiciaire il
y a un horizon pour chaque magistrat
instructeur qui est celui de la
manifestation de la vérité parce que
voyez-vous dans quelques mois d'un
peut-être quelques années il va y avoir
le procès et la famille certaine nombre
de questions parce que avec la
découverte de Marwan et bien grâce aux
enquêteurs ils ont pu peut-être
enclencher ce long processus qui sera
interminable qui est celui du deuil mais
maintenant on veut répondre à toutes ces
questions là et ce qu'on attend de la
justice c'est qu'elles prennent ce
dossier au sérieux que et bien les
investigations soient menées avec
sérieux et que et bien on se donne les
moyens de répondre à toutes les
questions qui sont légitimes
c'est-à-dire et je vous disais tout à
l'heure le pourquoi le comment qu'est-ce
qui s'est passé durant toutes ces
semaines avec l'aide de qui et bien
l'auteur présumé les auteurs présumés
ont pu dissimuler un cadavre Michelin on
dit c'est que apparemment il serait
peut-être pas tout seul Jérémy Jérémy
était avec sa colocataire qui est
d'ailleurs incarcéré mise en examen et
incarcéré il y a deux mises en examen de
personnes incarcérées c'est Jérémy et ça
s'accompagne à d'autres personnes ou pas
nous sommes nous sommes au prémices au
prémices de cette instruction et comme
je vous le disais avec l'aide de qui qui
a pu l'aider à dissimuler est-ce que
c'est dans son entourage déjà parce que
la médiatisation de ce dossier elle a
été initiée par la famille de Marouane
et ma présence ici Cyril parce que je
n'ai pas l'habitude de venir sur les
plateaux et j'aime à penser que le
procès une procédure judiciaire elle se
gère par l'institution judiciaire mais
force est de constater que dans ce
dossier là ça a porté ses fruits des
témoignages et que ça continue au
quotidien et des personnes les contacts
et nous sommes en collaboration avec les
enquêteurs pour peut-être aider
l'enquête voilà l'intérêt aussi parfois
de la médiatisation d'un dossier il y a
en plus des deux suspects il y a eu 6
autres personnes interpellées et il faut
savoir que ils ont mis sur l'affaire
huit enquêteurs chevronnées de la police
judiciaire d'Évry qui hallucine de
l'ultra-violence
quand ils ont découvert le corps ils
expertisent cinq scènes de crimes pour
savoir où Jérémy aurait tué Marouane et
il pense qu'il peut y avoir un réseau
derrière parce que ils l'ont arrêté
grâce à une écoute à un moment ils ont
mis tout le monde sur écoute il avait
fui près de Rouen donc il pense à une
organisation il pensait effectivement à
un périple sordide avec potentiellement
le corps comme disait Michel cachets
partout et il est mis en examen pour
assassinat donc assassinat ça induit la
préméditation possible donc vraiment là
on est au prémices d'une véritable
enquête et peut-être d'une filière
démantelée
vous êtes la tente de la victime comme
je l'ai dit il y a un instant
quand vous entendez tout ça quand vous
savez ce qui a pu subir Marouane vous
pensez forcément à votre à votre sœur
c'est la famille je pense à ma sœur la
douleur la famille vous êtes dans quel
état d'esprit là
dans la famille on est
on effondré on ça fait deux mois qu'on
se bat pour avoir des nouvelles ça fait
depuis le premier octobre qu'on cherche
Marouane qu'on essaie de trouver des
pistes de le retrouver vivant au début
bien sûr même si on se dit que on a plus
d'espoir c'est pas vrai on a toujours
l'espoir de le retrouver vivant même à
l'hôpital même n'importe où même mal en
point mais pas mort même si on se dit on
va le trouver mort c'est pas vrai on
n'est jamais prêt à entendre ça
et surtout pas dans ces circonstances là
et ça a duré deux mois et c'est trop
c'était deux mois de trop quand vous
avez appris que je vous dis les tortures
qu'il a pu subir on lit voilà c'était
extrêmement violent votre sœur
sa maman elle a pris ça comment elle va
pas bien comme comme une mère qui qui a
envie de savoir la vérité elle a envie
de ma sœur veut savoir ce qui s'est
passé réellement depuis quand comment ma
sœur a se pose mille et une question
elle veut savoir pourquoi pourquoi le
présumé coupable aurait fait ça pourquoi
est-ce que Marouane lui parlait de de
Jérémy qui disait des choses sur l'Est
qui disent non pas plus que ça Jérémy
c'était pas un ami d'enfance il a son
noyau d'amis d'enfance vraiment c'était
pas du tout Jérémy des c'est un ami
c'est un copain dit il y a quelques ils
habitaient pas loin l'un et l'autre et
ce ils se revoyaient depuis très peu et
Marouane ne fréquentait pas des rêves
parties ou quoi que ce soit comme on a
pu l'entendre Marouane
il y a plein de choses c'est pas que ça
parce qu'en soit on a perdu notre fils
on s'en fout de ce que les gens disent
mais un minimum de respect pour la mère
le père la famille parce que on entend
tout et n'importe quoi il y a des choses
qui sont vraies beaucoup de choses qui
sont fausses mais
voilà et Michel c'est vrai que pas mal
de choses qui ont été entendues sur ma
one et on se met à la place de la
famille des victimes qu'est-ce qui a été
dit voilà il est devenu le
soufre-douleur de Jérémie et on a dit
parfois on a sous-entendu qu'il pourrait
être mêlés à ce trafic ou cette
consommation de drogue ce qui à ma
connaissance du dossier est faux c'est à
dire qu'il est allé effectivement chez
cet ami pour une soirée à Arpajon il a
été victime d'un déchaînement de
violence peut-être d'ailleurs que ce
n'était pas le premier déchaînement de
violence parce que visiblement cet homme
était manipulateur et aurait pu en faire
quelques en quelque sorte une victime
récurrente voilà donc on a accusé à tort
Marouane d'être potentiellement mêlé à
extrêmement peiné sa famille en plus de
la douleur déjà qu'on perd un film sur
frère un neveu en plus on salisse on
s'allie on le salie déjà qu'on peut pas
se recueillir sur un corps parce que
c'est plus possible et en plus de ça on
le salie nous nous on peut pas entendre
ces choses là quotidiennement pour ça
que non veut que justice elle soit faite
on veut que les coupables ils payent
même si ça nous le rendra pas et ça nous
enlèvera jamais le chagrin et ce sera
jamais assez pour nous mais on veut que
justice soit faite et que et que
Marouane puisse reposer en paix et là
pour nous
pour nous là la chose principale c'est
de pouvoir l'inhumer dignement
et l'emmener au Maroc pour l'enterrement
dès qu'on fera
c'est Michel c'est une histoire
complètement incroyable aujourd'hui
Jérémy et sa compagne ils sont en prison
ils sont en prison ils sont mis en
examen ils ont dit quoi alors ils ont
avoué la même chose
quels sont les deux versions la première
version la version de
la version de Jérémy quand il est
interpellé en Normandie il reconnaît
rapidement
avoir une responsabilité dans la mort de
Marwan et il indique comment il dit quoi
exactement
et il indique l'endroit où se trouve le
corps ce qui était le principal pour les
enquêteurs de la police judiciaire
d'Évry c'était de retrouver le corps
donc ensuite une fois que ça a été réglé
il y a eu de longues auditions lui en
gros il dit
qu'il que Marouane est devenu fou à un
moment donné qu'il aurait pris un
couteau et qu'il aurait menacé sa coloc
et qu'il a voulu défendre ce que Jérémie
a voulu défendre sa colocataire et qu'il
aurait à ce moment-là attrapé attraper
Marouane et il aurait étranglé il y a
aucun problème dans cette version c'est
que la colocataire dit absolument pas ça
elle dit pas du tout
il a il l'a tué
lentement dans un espèce de rituel
sadique et je vais pas plus loin
mais que c'est il avait véritablement
l'intention de le de lui donner la mort
donc
je vois pas pourquoi cette femme
inventerait cette cette version
donc a priori je pense que c'est on s'en
verra l'instruction effectivement le le
confirmera certainement mais a priori ça
s'est passé
alors j'irai pas beaucoup plus loin mais
je dirais que c'est vrai que les
enquêteurs ont vu que le le Marouane
avait été roué de coups
longuement torturé sans doute
ce qui induit effectivement une volonté
au cours de plusieurs heures de de
mutiler puis d'assassiner quelqu'un
voilà donc pour eux vraiment
jérémy a tout fait pour tuer Maroine
sans qu'il y ait au préalable de prise
de couteau d'attaque de Marouane voilà
c'est un déchaînement de violence
absolument terrible même les enquêteurs
qui sont des enquêteurs expérimentés
sont
hallucines devant cette ultra violence
mettre aujourd'hui donc l'enquête
l'enquête avance bien comme vous l'avez
dit vous allez avoir vos réponses à vos
questions comme vous dites assez
rapidement vous pensez
assez rapidement il y a déjà un certain
nombre d'investigations qui ont été
réalisés
et certainement de questions auxquelles
nous avons trouvé des réponses
évidemment dans le cadre d'une procédure
criminelle et bien les premiers temps de
l'enquête les premiers temps de
l'ouverture d'information sont
absolument fondamentales parce qu'après
il y a un risque de déperdition
d'épreuves il y a et bien une enquête
sur laquelle on se penche un peu moins
et oui ça a bien avancé les informations
et les détails qui me sont donnés là par
Michel et bien je n'y ai pas accès je
suis pour dire en toute transparence
assez frappé de voir comment dans une
procédure judiciaire un journaliste à
plus d'informations avant même la partie
civile l'avocat de la partie ville qui
est et bien parti à la procédure alors
il y a deux obstacles à cela pour que je
ne puisse pas vous révéler un certain
nombre de faits d'abord c'est que je
suis soumis et tenu par le de créer de
l'instruction mais le second c'est que
la partie civile dans le cadre de notre
procédure pénale et bien n'a pas accès
au dossier tant qu'elle n'est pas
auditionnée par le juge d'instruction
voilà pourquoi avant quelques jours voir
quelques semaines et bien moi c'est
détaillé là que Michel vient de donner
je suis même pas en capacité de les
donner à Zakar de Marouane vous êtes la
tente de la victime qu'est-ce que vous
auriez à dire ce soir
j'aimerais dire que
que je parle en nous au nom de ma
famille quand on est peiné de tout ça et
qu'on ces passions on se relèvera
honnêtement c'est dur en fait on pense
pas vivre ces choses-là on le voit à la
télé dans vos émissions et on a suivi la
petite Lola comme et ça nous a touché
pourtant on était en deuil à ce
moment-là et
découvrir quelques semaines après que
Marouane il était aussi dans une valise
et pendant plus longtemps
malheureusement là la seule chose qu'on
veut c'est que la justice soit faite que
que les coupables ils payent mais qui
s'en sortent pas comme ça parce que ça
nous le rendra pas mais c'est un minimum
pour nous
et Marouane vendredi
et on va célébrer
ses obsèques à Aulnay-sous-Bois la
mosquée le vendredi ensuite on emmènera
au Maroc pour l'enterrer
et
au moins qu'il repose en paix et nous on
continue le combat on arrêtera pas on
arrêtera pas